you guys are just getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother i was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that i had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me i had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that i started doing was beating the sun
up every morning
i'm going to beat that sun up every
morning so that i had the discipline and
the control over my life
so i knew hey before that thing pops i'm
gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where i was was beat that
sun up no matter where i am i'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing i had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when i
was younger between 15 and 25 i was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends i have the same
weekends are for the week
i was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people
making poor choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things
quit hanging out with people that did
not have ethics and discipline in their
life that weren't committed to the same
things that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing i had to do was
become someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick start your day
get going in your day to give you a
sense of respect for yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning gives
me the sense of accomplishment that i
did what i said said i was gonna do that
i woke up when i said i would wake up
and i start building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that i can
go out to the world and maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when i go into
this meeting that i'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as i
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got so much more inside
you you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
seven rich people habits that you need
to try
enjoy
habit number two work to learn with
robert kiyosaki it was really hard
because i didn't like
i'm actually a very shy person
so learning how to sell was the hardest
thing i could do yeah but if i hadn't
spent four years learning how to sell i
never made it here i never made it here
so the entire time that you were here
you were preparing to jump to the other
questions
so every job is not so much for the high
paying job with job security
for not not everybody most people should
have job security because
they're not designed to be entrepreneurs
but if you're going to be an
entrepreneur then you better take this
job and say well which way am i going to
go yeah
so i knew
my job at xerox
was to go here and here and here yeah
not stay here
and i actually make so much money over
here that i don't need job security
so really that's the lesson when you
look at a job you look at what can i
learn
more than how much can i make
and i think that's the biggest challenge
and if you look for a job where you can
learn a lot
the harder the job
the better it is happen number three
focus on your strengths with dean
graziosi i think the biggest lie that
we've ever been told
throughout the history of our childhood
in the world is to work on our
weaknesses
it's the biggest lie
because when you work on your weaknesses
what does it do it makes you feel
inferior makes you feel
you know you lose your confidence you
don't have faith in yourself and then
all of a sudden we label ourself by the
things we suck at rather than getting
great at what we're already good at i'm
only good at i'm only great at a few
things i'm bad at everything else
but when i learn that ability so i'm
going to give you two quick stories here
when i was when i was going through
school i had dyslexia i mean right now i
finished my book it's done and i'm
trying to do the audio version i can't
even read my own book
i am having so much i'm on chapter three
and a half out of 12 and i've been at it
for two weeks i literally can't read
it's just my brain goes quicker than my
eyes or my eyes go quicker than my brain
but i listen to a book every week i
listen to an audiobook a week but i
can't just the way i comprehend but in
school i didn't know that i had the
unique ability of being a visual and
audible learner i just thought i was
dumb because i was in special reading
and i couldn't i couldn't get the words
to make sense and sink in right so in
school i remember teachers making you
feel inferior because i was weak in some
area when you realize it's the biggest
lie ever
and i'm going to carry two stories real
quick
so i wrote my first book it was called
totally fulfilled
and i wrote that book i
literally at that time only read a
handful of books in my entire life and i
wrote totally fulfilled i get done with
it i hire an editor
and she's so highly recommended i give
her the book she calls me two days later
and she says dean
it's not a book it's a 250 page
conversation you don't need an editor
you need a writer because you're not one
and and maybe she wasn't that rude but
it was pretty harsh i felt like it was
mrs thompson in seventh grade telling me
just just figure it out just sound it
out like i don't know how to do that um
so i for two days i go back to an old
story i start beating myself up why
would you think you could write a book
that's not your qualifications you could
barely read i go through all this stuff
for 24 48 hours and then finally luckily
i had a breakthrough like the hell with
it i just have a message i want to share
with the world so i called her up and
politely fired her i remember it as just
saying no thank you and firing her but i
probably was more polite so i take the
book back i hire an editor and i
basically said don't change my words
just make it so i don't look stupid and
he cleaned it up and that book was a new
york times bestseller in two weeks when
it hit the when it hit the air
[Applause]
i share that
i thank you and i didn't i don't show
that to brag i share that because that
book almost didn't happen if i would
have stayed in that state of mind by
thinking about my
weaknesses i would have not let that
book go any further i wouldn't be here
today i wouldn't have had that evolution
that was my first this is my sixth book
coming out i'm multiple new york times
bestsellers now but you realize those
weaknesses hold us back in life we all
everybody in this room is carrying
around something you think you're
terrible at and you think it's a mark on
who you are we all can't be good at
everything go after your passion find
out what you're good at and just get
great at it i'm not great at writing but
i can tell a hell of a story and there's
writers who do that for a living that
clean my stuff up
gets so good that you just pay for
people to do this you can't do well
that's success
so work on your strengths to help with
your weaknesses
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
happy number four always give your all
with edm
i remember going
all the work i put into this all the
hopes my family and i had all the travel
ball all the
everything we did all the games all the
great plays all the errors i made the
flat ball i dropped at fullerton you
know all that stuff i was gonna get
drafted then i did all that stuff right
the guys i played with
over
like a flicker man
like a flicker that crap was over and
we're on that bus ride back and i
remember thinking
man i should have tried harder
i should have played harder
i should have given this more the
you know that stuff guys do man you're
running sprints there's two dudes who
run every sprint full speed and then
there's a dudes who run eighty percent
six of them you know exactly what i'm
talking about right he's kind of cool
you know it doesn't matter i'm not the
fastest guy so no one will know when i
don't win the sprints
you know those guys you know exactly
what i'm talking about right this guy
kind of doesn't really catch the ball on
his throwing side in the outfield his
worm catches it over he does everything
wrong throws it back that's the thing
that cost a guy getting thrown out at
third and you lose by a run because you
just practice like that guy in the
bullpen is kind of like not really
focused he's just kind of getting loose
right instead of just laser focused on
everything he's doing all the time
right you don't want to leave here you
don't want it to end whether it ends in
the big leagues it ends in the minor
leagues it ends here or you never even
get on the field this year
okay
having wondered whether you gave it all
you got because it's going to transfer
into the man you become when you leave
here and most importantly it's going to
be your identity when you get tired when
you get fatigued when you get down when
you're in a slump it's your habits
rituals routines and your standards that
carry you through if you don't have good
habits you don't have good rituals so
you don't have good routines always in
your life you will fall down in bad
times and slumps and fatigue and stress
habit number five don't waste your
energy with glenn stearns i can look at
two things
worst thing that ever happened to me
it's embarrassing i'm at the age where
everybody knows i'm a dummy or wow i got
whole new friends you know i've got this
whole new set of friends which ended up
happening to me which
in two weeks i'm gonna have 45 of them
come out to my ranch this is from eighth
grade so i'm still friends with these
people right i have a child in 14 worst
thing in the world
right oh my god my life is over or wow
i've got a beautiful young
child you know and it's about how you
think you know to think of it i didn't
think of it like that
in the beginning that's my point when
did that change it just as life went on
i realized what i thought was horrible
became wonderful
and why do i spend energy on things i
cannot control
i had to fail fourth grade why am i
going to be upset about it
again i think about this after the fact
and realize don't spend energy on things
you can't control so as my life got as i
moved along i started
wasting less energy on things like that
and then realizing find the silver
lining what good came out of this
issue you know and i've had a lot of
them right so okay so i can't change the
things that
i could probably cry over so what what
lesson did i learn you know and then and
now my life in the last 15 years 20
years has been really
focused on all the the learnings you
know and not the
woe is me stuff because we all got those
how about number six get into action
with mel robbins we've been getting a
ton of questions about being paralyzed
with the fear of what other people think
and this is so commonplace i think every
human being on the planet is is
paralyzed in some aspect or some area of
their life because they're concerned
about with their parents or what their
friends or with their friends on
facebook or with their colleagues or
what they're uploading or their download
or whatever what their neighbors are
going to think if you are struggling
with this and you have not found it
helpful to
attack your thinking patterns then
here's a trick that i want you to try to
break the pattern of being paralyzed by
what other people think i want you to
pick one thing one thing that you've
been wanting to do that you've been
thinking about but you have stopped
yourself from doing because you're
concerned about what other people think
let me give you some examples maybe
you've wanted to go on a wellness
retreat but you think your spouse will
roll their eyes at you so you haven't
done it maybe you have a particular
facebook post or a blog so many of you
want to start a business or start
creating art but you're terrified of
putting yourself out there because of
what other people will think today we're
going to break that pattern what you're
going to do is you're going to pick one
thing you've been stopping yourself from
doing and you're going to do it you're
going to do it and the reason why i want
you to do this is because i know that if
you're still paralyzed you have not been
able to change your thinking patterns
yet that's cool no problem we're going
to try a different tactic i want you to
change this paralysis through action
because if you sign up for that class if
you go on that retreat if you create
your art if you post that blog post if
you start that business you will be
proving to yourself through the actions
that you're taking that you don't care
what other people think try that today
let me know number one what you've
stopped yourself from doing and number
two what you're committing to doing
today because one way to break this is
to attack the thoughts and change the
thoughts and get into action first the
other way to do it is to recognize that
you're paralyzed pick one thing that
you're gonna do and actually get it done
and habit number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
don't budget with david bach
because budgeting doesn't work yeah if
it worked everybody would do it and
everybody would start them and everybody
would stick to them um i you know i
spent 26 years in the financial service
industry
my first nine years were morgan stanley
and what i saw firsthand
in nine years i only had one client
write a check
discipline wise from budgeting from for
six months or more
the
everybody who saved they the one that
all my clients that really saved money
it was all automated so the message of
budgeting is instead of budgeting you
need to save automatically for whatever
you're saving for saving for an
emergency account you save automatically
money gets moved automatically into an
emergency account you want to save for a
dream trip to go to italy money gets
moved automatically into an italian
account your italy account yeah you're
gonna save for retirement it gets moved
automatically into retirement account
and so
it's it's this concept of instead of
using discipline and
willpower
you know driving yourself crazy because
budgets actually do drive couples to
fight
if instead you can focus on what you're
going to save automatically and where
you can eliminate all the fights
you have to have a plan for what you're
going to do when it gets hard when you
want to quit
when you know what has made you quit in
the past and when you know that thing
that made you quit is going to show up
again
what are you going to do when you have a
plan for how you're going to handle it
you'll stay committed when you don't
have a plan you're just going to react
and probably not react in a way that
will make you proud of yourself so this
is one of the biggest hacks that i've
discovered more recently in my career
and my adulthood whatever you want to
call it is typically on goals where
i would have a hard time following
through or it got really difficult or
scary or hard i would just push myself
more to say europe and carmichael you do
scary difficult to hard let's go do this
and i would summon the extra strength to
have to get through whatever i was
struggling with what i've done more
recently and why i love having this
video on is very timely is
trying to prepare in advance for some of
the obstacles that i know are going to
come so as an example i've done this
recently this week
last week i had a really rough week
i i wasn't sleeping very well i had some
big interviews from my channel i was
nervous about him i was staying up late
and when i when i can't sleep i get
restless legs
my legs are jumping all the time if i'm
in bed for more than 20 minutes my legs
start to get jumpy and i've tried
magnesium and i tried vitamin b and i've
tried a whole bunch of other things to
try to make it go away and it it's still
something that i'm struggling with um
the thing that's worked out the best is
actually stretching so i stretch out my
calves i think partly it's also because
i'm on a trampoline all day long and i'm
getting 20 000 plus steps in or jumps in
a day that i need to i need to stretch
my calves the other way for them to to
kind of i don't know de-stress anyway
maybe too much information but
what was happening last week was i would
lie in bed
i would do my stretching before lie in
bed and then
i get restless legs and so i would get
up and i would do some work or play some
league of legends or whatever and uh
then i would fall asleep and get tired
because i was so exhausted
and last week i had a 4 30 in the
morning day where that's when i went to
sleep at 2 30 in the morning day and so
i set a new plan on the weekend to say
okay
i can predict that this is gonna happen
right i can i can try to muscle my way
through like i normally would do and say
i'm evan carmichael i do difficult
things you know just stay in bed try to
muscle your way through it which
sometimes work and sometimes doesn't
work
i said you know what i'm gonna have a
plan this time what's my plan my plan is
gonna be i'm gonna do my stretching
before i go to bed and if i get the
restless legs jump your legs
that comes up after 20 minutes because i
haven't fallen on cpm i'm going to get
up and stretch again
and so that's what i tried
and it worked
and so i got up and i stretched i was
super tired i didn't want to stretch you
know i would rather just go work or
something and hop on my trampoline and
and then two hours later come back to
bed but i stretched for a couple minutes
and i said you know i'm just gonna try
it
let's try this i stretched for a couple
of minutes
i went back to bed and i fell asleep
like oh my god i feel amazing i didn't
stay until 2 30 or 4 30 in the morning
this is great because i had planned for
it more effectively so
whatever goal you set for yourself
it always comes back to habits right
like what are you doing on a consistent
basis and habits invariably will get
hard there will be moments where the
habit is really difficult to keep
when you're feeling bold and motivated
and confident and you had tons of sleep
and everything's going right it's
usually pretty easy to stay consistent
on the habits but when obstacles come in
your way it's going to be harder and so
you know the things that will trigger
you to want to quit right so for me it
was getting jumpy legs after 20 minutes
and being in bed when you can figure out
your trigger the thing that in the past
has made you quit why you've gone kind
of stop and start and stop and start and
stop and start what were the triggers
that made you stop what happened
and then when you're feeling bold
motivated confident have enough rest all
of that energy maybe that's today
to plan for the day is when you're not
going to have as much will you know that
this roadblock's going to come up again
when you know that this person is going
to call you and it's going to send you
down some spiral right this triggers is
going to make you stop the trigger that
is going to make you stop
what is your reaction going to be
and plan for that makes a huge huge
difference and allows you to stay
committed to your goals i was a dnf
student
i uh
i sucked at school
like i got
like i actually was so bad at school
that i had my
my admin my my assistant reach out to my
high school and get a copy of my report
card so i could put on instagram the
other day because people are confused
what success looks like or how you get
there it doesn't mean that you should
look at me and not do school it means
that you need to look at yourself and
figure out who you are
what are you good at what do you like
how are you going to get to the place
that you want to get to and so for me
i got four a's in high school my entire
career all in gym
right like i got a d in yearbook
you know and so to me there's just a
thousand paths out there and so
for me i'm curious about one by one one
by one for the 30 people in this room
where's their mindset where are they at
who are they listening to
what are they judging their self-worth
and their ambition based on
how are they counting the points because
when you're a youngster
you're looking at all sorts of different
things you're being affected by all
sorts of different voices
and for me the only thing that worked
even though i was getting d's and f's
and all my friends parents told me i was
a loser even all my teachers told me i
wasn't going to be anything even though
i didn't have stuff even though i was
i just was in my own head i knew exactly
who i was but the thing that i was
willing to do was i was willing to work
and the thing that my parents taught me
was not to dwell
not to cry about it i didn't have
when i when i rolled up on my mom when i
was nine when nintendo
was popping because
when it first broke i was like mom i
need nintendo she's like good go get it
how do you get to where you're at how do
you think the way you think how can you
self-actualize how can you be positive
do you have can you identify a reason
well for me it's a little easier than
maybe for some people because one when
you're down and out more than once you
don't know money no nothing and
something good happens oh boy this is
great but i was with all due respect i
was born i think positive i
my mom would always tell me my god be
careful mom i'm gonna be just fine i
always kind of think boring positive
you know then obviously when you're down
you go up you get even more positive
because you're so happy and then when
you have an abundance of something and
you get to share it with people and you
see a good end result it's just it's
happy if you ever you do something for
somebody else and ask absolutely nothing
in return it's the greatest high you'll
ever get now i went through the 60s okay
it's the greatest high you'll ever get
when you help somebody say that and you
ask nothing in return yes absolutely
nothing in return it's higher than
smoking anything is that what you how
you would describe a good giver
yeah when you give to somebody or
something or some environment whether
it's the environment for the planet or
for people uh and you ask nothing in
return you do it because it's the thing
to do
oh you get a good high everyone likes
being knowledge but do it sometime and
don't tell anybody you did it like
there'll be times austin especially i'll
go downtown and when i'm in l.a i'll do
it because i was homeless here once and
i'll hand out hundred dollar bills i'll
just go back to this for you
and i just keep on walking and one lady
they gave a stack to was a ten thousand
dollar stack she was just the kind of
sweetest lady and i talked to her a
little bit she told me a little about
her life and i said can i give you a
couple dogs oh no no i found out a way
to make it okay because i don't like to
ask for anything they said okay so i
just held her hand and i said can i put
a note in your pocket sure so i just put
a note in the pocket i realized he
spilled ten thousand output in her
pocket there was folded with a rubber
band i said you are so blessed
once you wait a few minutes before
reading my note say a little prayer then
read that out okay and i disappeared for
the audition when you first met de niro
that was yeah i mean that was one of
those incredible auditions that came
around that i i suppose every kid had
been waiting for for a long period of
time because
it's just not that often that you get a
starring role above robert de niro in
this incredible you know
screen playing with you know ellen
barkin and michael caton jones and it
was just
everyone was sort of fiending for this
role and um
i i got down i suppose to the final five
and there was like a last sort of day
toby was there and i
i do remember
thinking to myself uh i gotta do
something i gotta do something to stand
out
and um
in the audition it was art lindsen
michael kate and jones artleton who was
the producer
and de niro
and i remember uh it was a mustard jar
scene
and he had to jam a mustard jar in my
eye
repeatedly it was an abuse scene
and
the script sort of didn't call for it
but i got up and i he said now is it
empty is it empty and i got up and i
screamed
like completely unnecessary but i
screamed in his face
and i sat there you know
with my head uh you know looking like a
red tomato and and and everyone
started laughing at me in the entire
room de niro everybody was in hysterics
and i sat there frozen thinking oh my
god i just screwed this entire
opportunity up
and i just sat there frozen and then you
know bob in traditional de niro fashion
kind of just looked at me went
it's good
and uh
and and then you know we carried on
during the scene and i think i actually
had dinner with denir recently and he
told me no i was the one who said i was
the one who said you should get to get
the job you could have the biggest
craziest audacious idea in the world but
unless you can put one foot in front of
the other and make that first step
you're screwed and none of it matters
and again all it does is
it may allow you to you know
wrap yourself in some really elegant
rhetoric maybe it allows you to you know
be really followed on twitter and appear
at tech conference none of that matters
all of that crap washes out in the end
because if you suck you suck right and
you may be articulate but if you suck it
don't matter and you'll be revealed to
be a sham
what matters there is again it's just
that ability to understand what that
first
specific
set of things
need to be
um
with that broader bigger goal in mind
but if you can't put your first foot in
front of the other
and you know what's amazing most people
can't um because they get wrapped up in
the rhetoric of the vision and the
mission and all of this you know
grand deals you know blobbity blind that
they screw up and they're their own
worst enemies i i like revolution like i
like disruption right um but i'm
skeptical that things start that way i
think things let's just say ultimately
five years from now we look back and we
think that there is a massive sea change
politically
in the arab world
because of the arab spring
that fruit vendor self-immolated because
he was frustrated now maybe he started a
revolution but you know that took
courage to do what he did
that's not right or wrong in my opinion
but my point is you know that's an
example of how a revolution started with
you know a small or not a small thing i
mean it's a big thing but um one thing
that was tractable within him and i
think these broad-based kind of like you
know
i don't know gnarly expressions of like
how all of these huge crazy things can
happen they happen over many many many
many many years these are massive
tectonic plates it all boils down to one
person doing one thing and i think that
for a lot of people that's hard still
every year around february march i say
the same thing to myself and i set
myself the same goal let's just stop
there right and take a look at what i
just said because there's a real clue in
that first sentence
why does this goal pop up in march
the answer quite an obvious one because
summer is on the horizon
and you've got to ask yourself again
you've got to criticize yourself there
and say well why does summer matter well
because you know summertime is a time
where we wear less clothes we're a
little bit more vulnerable our bodies
are on show more and then you've got to
ask yourself okay so why is that
relevant well it speaks to the nature of
my motivation
my motivation wasn't to work out it
wasn't to be healthy because i want
long-term health benefits or to or to
feel great about myself as embarrassing
as this is to admit my motivation was so
clearly
to look good for summer
let's just break that down a second
look good for summer looking good as a
goal is measured by just one thing the
public's opinion of me
ladies opinion of me that's what we call
an extrinsic external goal success of
that goal will be achieved when the
public think i look good the next part
of that sentence right was for summer
the next part of my goal was for summer
which is a measurable time frame so once
summer is over
the job is done so the motivation behind
that goal was both extrinsic
and held within a time frame so when i
dropped that social media pick of me
topless in mykonos wherever i went this
summer mykonos and costa rica looking
good during summer and when i got the
compliments the likes the followers the
praise and when summer passed
unsurprisingly
so did my motivation
job done
my goal my reason my why was attached to
summer and also public opinion and both
had been fulfilled so as i pulled into
october and i tried to find the
motivation to go to the gym it was gone
going to the gym suddenly felt so
pointless to me and i had no idea why it
just did even when i managed to get to
the gym my workout was quite honestly
pathetic it was short it was like 25 30
minutes of me predominantly texting and
i didn't know why i just thought i
wasn't feeling great like you know like
a boat that had suddenly been
unanchored i was now just drifting
unconsciously without intention or real
motivation or without conscious
realization into the winter months into
bad habits into fat steve and the minute
i realized this this year i was able to
completely reset and sort of re-anchor
my motivation into things that were
intrinsically internally motivating and
without time frames i set myself the
goal of going to the gym just because it
makes me feel great talk to me about set
points that was something really
interesting in what you talk about
around the stories and things that we
carry that i found really interesting
sure so maxwell maltz wrote a great book
many many years ago in the probably the
70s
called psycho cybernetics right and
maxwell maltz was a surgeon who
performed surgery on people and what he
noticed is even after plastic surgery
that he performed on people some people
didn't see any change in their faces and
it was visible to everybody else but not
to them because they had a map of what
they thought they look like yes okay so
we all have
a map of reality we have a map of what
we think we look like
and any deviation on the physical level
to that map to that visual
representation we have in our brains
that doesn't match the map your brain
deletes or distorts it
so
when we were working with real estate or
when i worked with business owners in
addition to upgrading knowledge and
skills
if you think about how let's say income
we have set points for how much income
we earn so whether it's 10 000 a year or
20 or 50 or 100 or a million doesn't
matter we get this set point and then we
behave the way we need to behave and we
feel what we need to feel to earn that
income
and over a period of time it becomes
part of the brain's default mode network
so we develop set points for everything
and so if the set point's in the brain
and there's a psycho-cybernetic
mechanism in the brain a control and
response mechanism in the brain
and it's our brain
why not learn how
to reset the set point
and so now we're looking at what
technologies are available to help help
reset that
what
evidence-based methods are there to set
that or to reset that
and so when we take let's say
visualization right and you start to see
yourself even if the picture is not
clear in your mind of achieving the next
level of your success whether it's
releasing weight and keeping it off
getting into a relationship that you
love and are happy and whether it's to
make two or three or five times more
money and live a certain type of
lifestyle that allows you to do the
things that freedom
with having money allows you to do if
you start in your mind first and you
impress
that through conscious efforts into the
subconscious mind
it then causes thoughts and emotions and
behaviors
so i like to work from the outside in
and from the inside out so use both
i want every advantage you went to
tulane law school yes sir and you
graduate there and within nine months
tell them what happens because i want
you all to hear the ups and downs of
real life business and real life from
one of the most successful people in the
country so what happens at law school so
out of law school i have two choices for
jobs and it's a recession right one was
to be a real lawyer oil and gas
litigator you know big money all i want
to do is be rich is why i went to law
school and then the second was to work
in the internet and i got offered a job
to sell legal research online by west
publishing okay big big legal publisher
and so i go to my mom because you'll
appreciate this i go to my mom hey what
should i do mom my big advisor you know
i grew up with a single mom six kids and
she without blinking is like you need to
be a real lawyer because this internet
thing is a fad
so she calls the internet
and i always say because i like to teach
lessons biggest lesson of my life was
just because somebody loves you
doesn't mean they give you good advice
and i see so many people entrepreneurs
in relationships they ask for advice for
people that don't know anything my mom's
a second grade teacher right what does
she know about a beautiful soul but not
a technology expert no and if i would
have followed you know i think slowed
down or you know at least not allowed me
to have the acceleration i had so i took
the technology job right uh you know
single money hungry in a sales job in
the internet yeah and i made a fortune
nine months into it i had three goals
when i went to law school if i could
only pay back my law loans okay buy my
mom a home yep and buy my mom a car so
be very careful just because you love
them or they love you of thinking they
have some expertise in an area that you
don't right they probably don't and so
oftentimes we take advice from the wrong
person derails our dreams so that's less
than one more thing too yeah we end up
resenting them which is worse so all the
people that love us most we end up
resenting them because they gave us bad
advice and meanwhile we should be
accountable because we asked the second
grade teacher for internet advice
and that's the worst part in that year
when i was really broke and i was really
broken i was working at la unified
school district
i was miserable
i was miserable because i wasn't living
in my dream i was just doing a j-o-b
and then one day
i said well what what do i need to do i
i need to i need to buy my freedom
that's what i need to do i need to buy
my freedom well i don't know about
buying my freedom i don't know about
buying i don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up
my mother used to tell me oh this money
is burning my pocket so i know two
things about money it's hot
and we can't keep it long
we'd always have one week where we had
all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty
right come on come on some of you guys
know about that to this day i spend so
much money on groceries you guys oh my
god it's like i'm feeding like a family
of ten
because i'm so afraid of anybody ever
being at my house and being hungry
and so i i wrote a check to myself
jelani was three
a hundred and ten dollars
i took it to the bank
wells fargo
i started a new account
the next check i wrote
and just like the first check i put in
the memo line funding my dream i wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but i knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly there's
something here i'm not even clear about
it i don't know how clear you are but i
wasn't clear about it but i knew there
was a calling on my life greater than
working for la unified school district
and no disrespect to ella unified school
drinking it just wasn't my destiny
i wrote another check in two weeks
146 dollars
funding
my dream
now i started mailing the checks in
because i didn't want to see my balance
because i don't want to go shopping
because i you're going to repeat what
you learn right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned
so i mailed the check in and then i
wrote another check and i wrote another
check and every check i wrote i made
sure it was five percent more than the
first check the net the previous check
i sold my ultima i had a car note sold
my ultimate bought a clunker because it
didn't have a car note now i can write a
bigger check funding my dream
i moved out of my three bedroom three
bed three bath house and moved in became
a roommate with my friend who smoked i
put towels at the base of the door so
the smoke wouldn't come through the door
i was willing to be inconvenienced are
you
yes yes i'm just saying i'm just i'm
just showing you the story i just the
charge i just gave you
i stopped getting my hair done
that was when i started going natural
i stopped going out
i i stopped going out dancing i stopped
going out to dinners my family didn't
know what was going on they thought oh
my god you know it's la she's on drugs
but she's not losing weight so maybe not
i don't know what's going on
i kept writing bigger checks to myself
i mailed it to wells fargo
funding my dream
eleven hundred dollars
melded to wells fargo
funding my dream
i still
wasn't clear
what the dream was
i just knew i had one
and it was being born through me
and i needed to give it a chance
that's all i knew
you don't have to see 2 000 feet in
front of you just see 200
and run to the 200.
yes yes you don't have to see it all
three and a half years later i'd written
a check to myself every two weeks for
three and a half years
i didn't go out for three and a half
years i didn't go dancing i didn't get
my hair done i did get my nails done for
three and a half years are you willing
to be inconvenienced for your conviction
i walk in to wells fargo three and a
half years later
and i said hi god bless you hi
my name is lisa nichols she was oh my
god
you're the fun of my dream lady
i was like
yeah i guess i am
and all of a sudden all the tellers came
running around
the manager came they're like oh my god
okay oh my god we have been wondering we
all got the same question y'all know
what the question is right
what's your dream
i was like um
i'm not sure
but i know that it includes inspiring
people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
get having to be willing to give
themselves a thousand second chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
i'm not sure what it's going to look
like
but it's just going to help people
i said i came to check my balance i've
been writing a few checks to you guys
that say yes you've been writing a lot
i said i just want to check my balances
you don't know your balance i said no i
got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home because my mama
said money burns her pocket and i don't
want it to burn my pocket i wanted to
pay for my freedom
i said i just came to see what my
balance was if i had enough to fund my
dream as it gets clearer
she wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me
i looked at it i said
oh no my name is lisa shantay nichols
and my social security number i said
that is not my money and i am not taking
that money because you're probably gonna
want it back
so just fix that error right now
and they looked at me
they said you really
don't think that's yours
i said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank
or ten thousand dollars in the bank
that's
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
in the bank
they said miss nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said miss nichols
whatever your dream is
i think you can fund it now
i looked at my son jalani
who now was five or six and i said
jelani
our lives are gonna be a little
different now baby
jilani said
yeah
mommy can we
can't we now go to mcdonald's
see for three years i've been telling
jelani i'll make you a big mac
mama makes big macs better than
mcdonald's
and so begin
with hundred and ten dollar check
so i don't know what yours is i don't
know
what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right
yes yes
and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the best the next
best step this is the first step
and so i just stopped by to let you know
you're on the right path
and and as you ramp up
as you ramp up you're going to have
questions you're going to be afraid i do
more things afraid now than i do
fearless
because the bigger you play the bigger
your breakdowns
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one
every single one of my errors has
required me to call an attorney
[Laughter]
like they're just big
because i'm playing big
i'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here
be willing
to go to the edge
and not just lean over
and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump
and watch them soar and look through the
windows at all the people who are living
great lives don't just go to the edge
and feel it
be willing to lean
feel your heartbeat
feel it
that lets you know you're alive to let
you know you're okay
fear fuels you
fear lets you know go get more
information fear let you know step a
little later and study fear let you know
get up a little earlier fear let you
know ask for help fear is informing you
it's not stopping you it's just another
emotion like love and compassion and
gratitude we just made it paralyze us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear i feel it and i'm moving
forward anyway i feel it and i'm gonna
love anyway i feel it and i'm gonna
invest in me anyway i feel it and i'm
gonna show up and play anyway when you
get connected with fear it becomes your
best friend and when you stand on the
edge
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap
anyway everyone has a gift everyone can
contribute if they're empowered and so
that's the secret have a society have
institutions have people that empower
others that enable them
to
find their gift turn it into valued
skills and then apply it in a way that
enables them to succeed by contributing
to others
and see how simple this is yeah and
i mean the problem is you need a society
that is relatively based on the
principles of equal rights and mutual
benefit where people succeed by
assisting each other
and everyone has the opportunity to
realize their potential now that's
utopian there's no society that's been
perfect at that but even ones through
history that have had a small degree of
that
then
what these people can do that no one
suspected could do anything have done
extraordinary things
and change societies and so that's what
we try to do is go find those people to
solve a problem to eliminate an
injustice and then back them and combine
our capabilities with theirs to enable
them to do even more to help even more
people what i call this is applying the
principles of human progress this
involves three different things it
because
it requires believing in yourself
believing in other people empowering
them
from the bottom up having them realize
that no one's good at everything we're
all just good at a few things so we need
to partner with people who have
complementary capabilities so this gets
to frederick douglass's philosophy that
made him such a great uh social
entrepreneur to unite with anybody to do
right and no one to do wrong so those
are some of our guidelines but as i say
then the starting point in all this is
to recognize that everybody can
participate in this everybody can
contribute and succeed if you're a
closed system you close yourself off
from the rest of the world you try to do
everything yourself and you're going to
fall behind you probably die
right quickly and that's true for an
organization and that's true for society
so what does that tell us it tells us
things about immigration tells us things
about free speech and open inquiry it
tells us about trade it relates to
ricardo's law of comparative advantage
division of labor comparative advantage
when that started to be allowed
practice rather than everybody having to
do everything themselves
that's when
prosperity started to take off and
poverty started to decline in the 18th
century the one thing
i i'm not
smarter than anybody else but i can
outwork you
and uh my key to success for you or for
anybody else is make sure you're the
first one in there every day and the
last one to leave don't ever take a
lunch break or go to the bathroom you
keep working you never know when that
opportunity is going to come along and
at solomon brothers uh the managing
partner of the company bill solomon was
the second person in i was the only
other one in the big trading room so if
he had needed to borrow a match in those
days people smoked cigars and if he
wanted to ask something about a
newspaper or a stock he came over and so
we became buddies i would never have
gotten to talk to the managing partner
of a big company on a first name basis
if it wasn't for the fact that the two
of us are there billy i'm getting coffee
would you like some uh and i can bring
you that and at the end of the day the
number two guy john good friend he was
the last one to leave except for me and
we'd share a cab going up town or take
the subway train going uptown together
and you know every opportunity ever had
it was i think a lot a lot of them was
because i was there at the time and
that's the one thing you can control you
can you can't control your luck but the
harder you work the luckier you get you
can't control
that you're the smartest guy they'll
always be somebody smarter
but if you're there then you absorb
things you put things together in a ways
that if you didn't have all that
experience it's like skiing
i've said
reading a book on skiing doesn't teach
you how to ski
you gotta go and you gotta ski and get
lots of miles under your skis and
incidentally if you don't fall you're
not skiing hard enough and you're not
learning anything so if your career has
ups and downs i got fired didn't turn
out so bad but you know you can start a
little business and maybe it doesn't
work and after a while you've got to say
be smart to say hey i tried it don't let
your ego get in the way i can't keep
doing this i've got to earn a living but
you know a year from now i'm going to
come up with a better idea and then i'll
go back and do it again
and have that drive to
look at the bright side and i've with
the exception of
i've always
never there's never been a day that i
haven't looked forward to going into
work even the days i knew i was going to
get beaten up even the day i knew i was
going to get fired i'd never been fired
before i wonder what it's like okay
let's go find out yeah and i've never
looked back i i find it fascinating
people spend and we're doing this in
this country we're spending all our time
trying to blame people and figure out
why we got to where we are now rather
than focusing on how you get out of
where we are now and make it better
and successful people
look to the future and unsuccessful
people look to the back look behind them
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god you know you don't need 140
you know 835 you may need 115 or
something like that and
and but you do need discipline
you have to wait until you see the fat
pitch to swing at
because investing is a no-call strike
game you know if i were a baseball
player and i only like pitches
two inches above my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get called out on strikes in
baseball
you have to you have to swing at pitches
that you you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but
it's a marvelous game to be in because
there are no called strikes and you can
simply wait for that one time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years when you really know
what you're doing where you like the
price where you like the people running
the business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime the most
powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle very close proximity that
live at a higher temperature in that
area than you do for example in your
faith let's just say you're a 75 degree
or in your faith you've already seen
this you can't possibly begin to
regularly associate with good godly
people who pray regularly who try to
live righteously and are 110 120 degrees
of of faith in their life and not have
that proximity heat you up now you won't
get to where they are you'll get to
somewhere between where you are at 75
degrees and they are at 110 over time
you become 100 degree and you alter the
thermostat setting through association
same in business if you and i were to
hang around each other every single day
and let's say you were a 75 degree or in
business hypothetically and i don't know
that about you but let's just say you
were
and i was 150 degree and we hung around
each other all the time don't you think
through that association right
especially if you had two or three or
four people like me in your life that
just over time you don't even feel it
you're at 80 you're 85 you're at 90
you're at 95 and that's where you are we
understand the power of this with our
children
because we know at school the teachers
have influence over them they're mentors
but the people that really have
influence over our children are for
their friends because they're around
them all the time and so we know it's
that's their temperature this is true in
fitness if you're a 75 degree of fitness
at every meal every day at the gym all
your associations hypothetically
speaking where with someone who was
shredded and fit the way you wanted to
look at 150 degrees you know over time
you get heated up and so you can't be
with someone every day you can't be with
them all the time but the key is to get
more proximity in the areas that matter
with people whose thermostat setting is
higher than yours i am a product you are
listening to me right now because i've
been so obsessed with this concept of
adding new associations to my life that
live in the areas that i want to improve
in at higher temperatures than me it's
my obsession to this day i'll give you a
secret one of the reasons i even do my
show is i know that i'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
i'm obsessed with the power of
association but i don't just associate
see
all personnel says yeah you're the five
people you hang around
kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time
of studying them of observing them of
asking questions of the fact that you
should be altering your thermostat
setting that's when it really moves it's
not just hanging around it's consciously
and intentionally spending time with
people
where you allow it to impact you where
you study them where you really observe
them where you're open to their
influence there has to be a level of
trust before you can do that where you
surrender yourself to them but it's not
just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of association is the main way to do it
i'm very lucky to have been in
silicon valley and silicon valley is
very lucky to have
been able to benefit from you know the
semiconductor
boom and then software and now internet
and mobile
i mean i think it's
there's a huge amount of luck there
but the luck also comes from
taking many shots
you know so many failures you know if i
told you all the dumb things that i did
um you know we'd have to have much
longer session
uh and and the successes you know they
often are
chance i mean i mentioned the google
brain work that they were just off in
the corners like okay fine just you know
do your thing
uh our um
you know verily which is uh our
subsidiary that does a wide range of
healthcare innovation now i really
started with this glucose sensing
contact lens project
um and that was another one where i said
uh this fellow babak and brian otis who
were working on it
uh you know
and they wanted to put a computer in a
contact lens and i was like you know
what that sounds crazy but
you know you go do your crazy thing you
know you can only have a couple people
work on it i'm not going to give you a
lot of resources
but you know sure if you put a computer
in contact lens good for you
and yet here they are
uh you know a few years later and
they're you know running uh you know
they're doing serious studies now they
have a big partnership with artists and
alcon
uh and they are um you know hopefully
going to bring those to market
alongside with a bunch of other projects
that that has spawned
and i didn't know anything about that
and i never would have predicted or
guessed that
i think we're just lucky to have the
environment that tolerates
you know making lots of risky bets and
tolerating the failures that inevitably
result
revisit your orientation to wealth if i
say to you
rich people what does that bring up for
you
when you think about rich people what do
you think of
are they good
are they bad are the rich one two three
four percent of the world good people
bad people what do they like what are
their values like do you want to become
one of them you know i don't know about
you but sometimes you discover that
where you live or where you came from or
what you heard of about money in your
life is absolutely unconsciously driving
your life today like for example for me
i grew up in a very difficult economic
situation i grew up in a very difficult
town and place an old irish mining town
that had been economically depressed for
nearly a century where people didn't
have a lot and people really struggled
just you know very blue-collared try to
get through the day lots of poverty lots
of people struggling and i can share
with you that there was this
conversation often about people on the
other side right there's people on the
other side of the tracks or there's
people on the other side who are
wealthier and there was a lot of the
culture that i grew up in where oh those
rich people
and there was this projection of
frustration or restlessness or anger
towards quote unquote rich or wealthier
people and because of that i didn't ever
want to become one of them
and so i didn't for a very long time
it's funny because one of the basic
human drives that we have is the human
drive for congruence we want to be
congruent in our thoughts and our
behaviors so if we think that a type of
person is negative our body and our mind
and our subconscious will do everything
it can not to become that right we don't
want to become something that we think
is negative so if you think wealthy
people or rich people are negative guess
what you're never going to attain
wealth
and that's what's important to revisit
all those old stories and all those old
phrases we heard growing up you know you
know uh money's the root of all evil or
people are you know people with money
are insensitive or people with money are
selfish or if you gain more wealth and
success in life you're just gonna be
more busy and you're never gonna have
time for your family and you're gonna
forget everybody whoever came along with
you and never supported you and oh my
god and all these things right we think
this big story about money
so what's your story about money
is it positive is it negative is wealth
something that will bring you more joy
more happiness more ability to give and
serve and do something with in your life
or is it something that terrifies you
because you think you won't be able to
handle the obligations that come along
with oath you worry that if you make
more money or to make more money you're
gonna have to be away from your family
more so you never try
see most of us have a lot of really bad
assumptions about what it would take to
succeed but also what it would take to
make more money and ultimately to keep
more money to sustain more money because
i bet you also think oh i heard it's
lonely at the top
well who wants to be lonely and if rich
people are bad who wants to be a bad
person and rich people are
you know pushing family members away and
becoming selfish who wants to become
that
so you've got to redefine what wealth
would mean for you specifically not what
the culture told you it could be i will
share with you that after you know i've
been through the ringer financially in
my life i mean i grew up with nothing
and then i started making something in
corporate america and built something of
myself i started working really hard i
got a good job i started climbing sort
of that corporate ladder i discovered
that the corporate world wasn't for me
and so i left i quit and to start my own
dream of doing videos and and writing
and doing my seminars and and and all of
the things that i do now and you know
what
i did exactly what people predicted i
promptly went bankrupt i went broke i
had no idea what i was doing and it
would have been easy at that point very
easy to quit very easy to say oh you
know what money's not for me but i
thought no i know that sometimes you
know if you don't have money you can't
sustain the message if you're not
earning then you can't keep giving and i
thought i got to change my orientation
here i got to get serious
about making money and do it without all
the guilt and the nonsense that my
culture or the past or the popular media
thrusts on people with money because
guess what there are also
philanthropists there are also people
who take money and they support their
family they send their kids to college
they get safer cars they do good in
their community they buy books for kids
they do things that matter with their
wealth and matter of fact that's most
wealthy people
and people it's really hard for to
believe that if you're not wealthy yet
but i can share with you after i had my
big breakthrough and i started learning
how to build more value in the
marketplace everything shifted for me
for the first time in my life i had
money and the funniest thing is i didn't
even know what to do with it because i
never had it before so it was just there
and guess what i started finding things
to do with it no problem as you will
but those things i found to do with
money they didn't tear me from my family
or make me a bad person
i gave more to charities
i spent more time with my family i could
take them on vacations we could go to
the caribbean together i i could do
things for people that i love little
gifts and little treats and little
acknowledgements that made them feel
happy i found ways to utilize it that
made me happy and now i had no negative
associations to it anymore
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more rich people habits to
try check out the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there sometimes
it's impossible i like things quiet
i shut the door actually at the office
because i i don't want to hear anybody
talking outside the way you have meaning
in your life
is you discover your gift